samantha's with us in dallas texas hi
samantha welcome to the ramsey show
hi thank you so much for having me today
sure
how can we help um i was calling because
um i started your program
this past october and i'm on baby step
two
and i'm currently reading the total
money makeover and my question is
something that you talk about
is not giving the government a um
interest-free loan for your taxes
and um i get back a pretty hefty
um tax return every year and i was just
wondering how i can
set up my taxes so i get more now
to put towards my debt without going
um when i file my taxes next year okay
what was your refund the last two years
um 2000 and 2200
okay has anything changed substantially
in your life
this year like did you buy a house have
a baby get married
none of the things okay so nothing
that's going to affect your taxes so
you're likely going to get a
2000 to 2200 refund again
right is that right can really change in
my deduction correct
okay so uh uh i would sit down with
uh just go to your payroll department at
your company and say i need to fill out
a form to change my deductions and i
need to help you
you can help me calculate it i need to
change my deductions
by 200 a month
okay i need to bring home 200 more than
i'm bringing home now
that's 2400 a year so you'll be under
withholding a little bit
so you'll owe a couple of hundred when
you do your taxes next year
if you want to do 150 then you would get
a small refund
that'd be 1800 but uh and and you know
you get a couple hundred dollar refund
that'd be okay too if you want just be
safe go ahead and just do 150.
let's let's increase your take-home pay
i want to claim enough deductions or
fill out a form
to increase my take-home pay by 150
a month that's 1800 a year and if you
have a 2 000
tax bill that means you i mean if you
have a 2 000 refund
that means you wouldn't be getting that
you would have gotten it early except
for
uh 200 of it so you get a 200 refund
instead of a 2 000
tax refund and that would be a very
smart thing to do
so yeah i'll just reduce your three and
let me tell you that the the
irs tables don't work
so are they like well i'm a single young
woman and i don't have any deduction
deductible or i don't have any um
dependents and so i claim zero
dependence
and then it creates this huge refund so
that
it obviously the calculations on don't
work so you can't use
what your you know your real number of
dependents are
to set the thing up so you have to
actually just do the math
the other thing if you want to get more
sophisticated on this folks go ahead and
just do your tax return
for this year in advance
and then you'll know exactly what your
tax bill is
and have that amount taken out of your
check
and no more and no less because that's
what you're withholding is not supposed
to be over withholding
and a refund comes from over withholding